And hi to you,
I hope you are well.
Today,
we will focus on the
Part 3 of the chapter on social structure,
the senior sociology chapter.
We will be interested in the thought of Carl Marx
and the thought of Max Weber,
2 thinkers of the time
who have a certain vision of the social structure,
who thinks of a certain
in the way of social stratification.
Here we go.
And we start with the thought of Carl Marx
who is a thinker,
an economist,
19th century philosopher and sociologist.
In the manifesto of the communist party
ofmille-huit-cent-quarante-huit
which he co-wrote with Hangeuls,
he highlights this sentence,
the history of any society up to the present day
has been the history of class struggle.
Take this sentence back,
you can use it as a hook
or even for 1 explanation,
It will look good with your proofreader.
For him,
society is divided,
or in any case is progressively divided into 2
social classes.
They split in 2.
These 2 social classes,
it is the capitalist and
the.
The capitalist,
"it refers to individuals who have the means to
production.
It is individuals who seek to maximize their
benefit by exploiting the workers.
The,
the,
them,
inevitably reducing
to defend their interests and interests,
is the fact of increasing the maximum possible
their income.
So
these 2 social classes have antagonistic interests,
have conflicting interests.
In this conflicting vision of the Society,
the workers do not hold the means of production,
all they hold is their work force
and they get exploited,
see even overed by capitalist liberalization.
For Karl Marx,
it's simple,
to know what social class you belong to,
you just need to know if you have the means to
production
or if you only have your workforce.
When we talk about the means of production,
we are actually talking more or less about fixed capital
in economics,
i.e. locals,
machines,
tools and so on.
,
the capitalist,
they are the big owners,
the big industry bosses of the time.
For karlmax,
the working class,
the proletarian,
it is 1 class that is revolutionary,
because by dint of being
exploited by capitalist liberalization,
she will start to defend her interests.
For Carl March,
it is important to distinguish
what we call the class itself
of the class for oneself.
What is a class in itself?
1 class in itself is 1 class that exists objectively.
This is 1 class that exists in reality,
but not necessarily in people's heads.
To do this,
you have to go from class to class
to the class for oneself.
Class for yourself,
it is 1 social class that also really exists,
but in which
individuals have begun to become aware
that they seek to
this class.
Let me explain,
so it's clearer to you,
let's imagine that you.
Wake up in the morning
quite early in the morning mist,
that you arrive in your industry,
that you do hyperrepetitive gestures,
all this for a rather miserable income
because you are being exploited
by capitalist liberalization.
You are objectively 1 worker,
you are objectively 1 proletarian.
Objectively,
you are dominated
in uh.
This production process.
But at the beginning,
you don't necessarily realize your condition.
You don't surrender
necessarily counts that you belong to the category of
dominated.
It's by looking at your colleagues,
for example,
by talking to them,
by sharing your difficult working conditions,
that you will gradually realize
of your real place in the economy
and in production,
and the fact that you are dominated.
And it's from the moment you
realize that you are a worker,
that you belong to the category of proletarians,
that you're going to start to uh,
have demands,
to want to reverse the system.
That's why for max,
the passage from the class itself to the class
for oneself is necessary
so that the proletarians,
gradually,
capitalist society.
But for that,
you have to realize that you
actually belong to
to the dominated category,
to the category of proletarians.
For Karl Marx,
the class struggle is inevitable
and the victory of the is not in doubt.
Unfortunately,
history will prove him wrong.
I end this Marxist analysis of society
By telling you that he,
he has 1 vision that is united,
dimensional,
that is,
for him,
the it uses only 1 criterion to succeed in stratifying,
to prioritize the company,
the possession or not of the means of production.
We therefore speak of dimensional united analysis,
unlike Weber
which has 1 multidimensional analysis.
For Weber,
the company is divided into 3 specific orders,
the economic order,
the social and political order.
Within each of these orders,
there are specific groups.
For example,
in the economic order,
it does speak of social class.
Like Carl Marx,
for him,
1 social class is,
uh.
brings together individuals
who have the same standard of living,
that is,
the same possibility of access to the good.
The 2nd order,
the social order,
contains groups of statues,
groups of statues,
are groups of individuals
who have the same level of social prestige,
the same level of fame if you prefer.
For example,
the teacher of the time
had a very special position in the village,
he was known and recognized for his social position.
It can be beneficial for the parish priest
for example.
He has a high level in this social order,
it is thus 1 particular group of statue.
3rd order is the political order
within which there are political parties.
If you are
according to your level of political power,
in fact, quite simply.
It is therefore clear that Max Weber's analysis
is more dimensional.
For him,
we can analyze society
in 3 different dimensions.
For the baccalaureate,
if it falls on that point,
you will often be asked to oppose the 2 visions.
I give you a little summary of what you absolutely must
understand,
explain and illustrate.
You must put in
before the fact that Carl Max's vision,
it, is united,
dimensional.
We know how we place you in the process of
production,
simply because you have
or not the means of production,
and that as a result,
for him,
there are only 2 social classes,
the capitalist bourgeois and the proletarians.
While Weber's analysis is multidimensional
since it distinguishes the 3 orders I told you about,
with the social classes for the economic order,
groups of statues for the social order
and political parties for order,
uh, politics.
Carl Marx's analysis is 1 analysis called
realistic
because for him,
classes really exist,
in fact,
the social classes are self-aware,
while to veber,
we are talking about an analysis that is nominalistic.
He just names,
uh,
these different groups that have been discussed.
But for him,
individuals do not have
necessarily awareness of belonging to these groups.
For him,
these groups,
it is above all a statistical tool,
1 model in fact to think about society.
that's why we oppose carlmax's realistic vision
to the nominalist vision of Max Veber.
And you can also highlight the fact that Carl Max
a 1 view that is rather conflicting,
we said it,
with the class struggle,
the capitalist bourgeois against the proletarians.
While veber,
it has 1 vision
which is 1 little more pacified than social relations.
It tells us that these groups are not
necessarily in struggle,
simply because
we have seen that within these groups,
there was not necessarily class consciousness,
it wasn't necessarily classes for you.
I hope all this helped you,
I hope you understand better.
If this is the case,
don't hesitate to like,
subscribe,
to share this video
and see you soon for the next one.
Hi